[Applause]
i'd like to welcome
everybody we have an exciting special
edition of down the middle
uh this is being recorded on non-farm
payroll friday
and i can't tell you how excited i am
and how privileged you are and i
am to have david rosenberg with us he is
the founder
and president of rosenberg research uh
we know him as rosie
and we have long long long uh enjoyed
the insights that he has provided and
again
i'm i'm just i cannot be any more
excited that we're here on non-farm
payroll
friday so uh let's jump in david welcome
um thanks daniella i remember the days
when uh
you and i would go on before the number
uh with our good friend sarah eisen on
cnbc
yeah i have to talk about our forecast
you know
half an hour before the numbers came out
so
it's a little easier to do the analysis
post reports
then kind of forecast it ahead of time
well yeah but i mean you know look
let's jump in let's jump in it's the
mammoth miss
it is the mammoth miss what's happening
here
you know our good friend steve blitz
says that there are literally two
jobs markets in america today there's
one that was affected
by the pandemic and there's one that's
very permanent
you called out an increase in people who
have been out of work for 27 weeks
or more what does this tell you
well there's still a considerable amount
of long-term damage
or what the deep hell would call a
scarring uh
to the labor market uh you know coming
out of the uh
of the pandemic so we have a rising
share
of people who have been uh out of work
looking foolishly for a job for at least
uh a half a year uh the number of
permanent job losses uh
took a very big leap up uh in the month
of april so you're
still seeing a lot of the uh you know
the permanent damage uh
take place uh in the labor market that
came through loud and clear in the
household survey today
and uh look there's a lot of other
things that were very interesting
beneath the veneer of just the week
headline
uh which was you know the sort of things
that jay powell told us that the fed is
looking at
at his last presser following the fomc
meeting and of course they talked about
this incessantly as well
uh more inclusive approach towards uh
our holistic approach towards the labor
market
so they're looking at the have-nots as
you said before
so a lot of the people that got hurt the
most on the pandemic
you know they're waiting for that part
of the jobs pie to come back
first and foremost and so from that end
you know you're looking at minorities
uh actually it was a negative number
there was a net job loss for minorities
in the member today for women
uh the same thing uh for people without
a high school education
and the youth people between the ages of
20 and 24.
uh all negatives those are the parts of
the contraction
that you saw beneath the veneer today so
uh
all those things are telling you that um
if you know labor market you could
argue was is in the process of healing
still a year after
the lows in employment um but there's
still a long way to go before we're
fully healed many years
uh so a 35 hour work week
um i'll tell you i've been traveling
around
the united states i've listened to
people
um we're both friends with bill
dunkleberg national federation of
independent business
a record 44 of small businesses say they
cannot get a worker
you cannot drive a block at texas
the midwest florida where i am you can't
drive a block without seeing a help
wanted sign
so what is going on here i mean a 35
hour work week
speaks pretty that that that's a pretty
big marker that that backs
the notion that companies can't get
workers
well i mean you you hear a lot about
that and um
i think that we're still living through
this uh
this uh historical
period of time i mean the we're still
not
completely through the pandemic i mean
it's nice to know
uh that in the united states uh no more
than 40 percent of the population
are already been vaccinated but that's
still a process
and we're still not at herd immunity and
so you have a lot of people
uh that might still be nervous about
going back to the workplace for health
reasons
um you could still have people that are
having difficulty
even affording to have their kid
in child care interestingly enough
that was one area where employment was
up last month
and we have a situation where you know
we have um
over 16 million americans on at least
one benefit program
and before the pandemic uh that number
was closer to two million
in terms of people receiving at least
one benefit so here we are
uh the economy almost fully reopening
not totally but
largely reopening we've got this
gargantuan
uh you know gdp growth on our hands
and yet we have a situation where
employment is lagging well behind for a
variety of reasons
um but i think that when you have eight
times the number of people on at least
one benefit program it does support
i'd say anecdotally it gives an
ammunition to
the view that these people that you know
we call them on the dole or these people
that are receiving
these various very generous benefit
programs
are getting paid more to stay out of
work than when they were working
and look you can see that in terms of
you know what is the preponderance of
the unemployment
is really in those consumer service
sectors
that are low paying low-skilled
and that's where most of the
unemployment has come from
and so when they therefore are getting
paid not to go back to their old job
more than they were making before well
there's a big incentive
not to go back to work so i think that
one of the things that jumped out of the
employment numbers today was the fact
that average early earnings
were up 0.7 percent um but they were
really only up significantly
in those low-skilled low-wage
areas in consumer cyclical services
accommodation leisure uh retail
and so that's what companies are having
to do they got a pony up now whether
it's through pay sweeteners
or just higher wages to bring these
people back in look we'll see how
permanent is the one thing we know for
sure
is that these extended jobless benefits
will expire by the end of the third
quarter
whether the the administration and
congress wants to
roll these over it'll be situational
um but i was saying answering your
question and look i know that i'm taking
my time answering it is that we're still
living in the pandemic
we're still living it this is still you
know historians will be writing about
this period we're in right now i'm not
talking about a year
ago or six months ago we're still living
through this experience and so there's
tremendous
distortions in the economic data
and so the answer your question is yes
people are being incentivized not to go
back to work
uh and even after uh companies
paid up to bring people back in uh
there's still a mountain of
unemployment in these particular sectors
so so who knows what it's going to take
to bring them back in
uh probably uh more signs that the
country is vaccinated that'll provide
some confidence from the health
perspective
and why don't we give a time and see
what happens after september
if these generous jobless benefits roll
off
probably we'll see a lot more people
come back to work uh and look that's
only
you know what five months away uh but
that that i think is is
you know i quoted cosmo castorini in one
of my pieces recently
when he's selling loretta in the kitchen
from the movie moonstruck
uh that everything is temporary and so
this situation where we're seeing some
wage growth to bring people back in i
think that again is going to be
temporary
and i think once the jobless benefits go
back to normal
uh we'll we'll find a lot of these
people that were you know willing to
stay in the sidelines
and not working will come back in that's
my yeah you know it was interesting um
last night i uh the hyatt that i stay at
here
in in florida uh it was the bartender's
first day at work
and i said man you're a you're a regular
patriot and he said well i know i can
make more
sitting at home he's like but you know
there's something to be said for karma
and i'm like okay all right well i'm i'm
happy to happy to meet you and i gave
him double the tip that i would
otherwise
uh and that's just i mean i i think i i
think you're right i mean september the
6th
is around the corner and that's when
these benefits
expire and i like to think that
that summer jobs that you know that some
of these jobs will be appealing
to teenagers when you know after
memorial day when they get out of school
so um i'm kind of in your camp with
let's wait and let's wait and truly test
because you've got some fascinating
numbers on
the sheer number of the true pool
of of unemployed can you walk us through
that math
well look when you um when you tally up
all
the uh idle labor resources in the u.s
and it's not just a simple case of
looking at the official
unemployment count because actually when
you look at the employment number that
came out today
the vast majority of those people coming
back into getting a job
was actually not the unemployed it was
people who were actually
previously not in the labor force but
we're waiting on the sidelines not
technically canada's unemployed
so you have to take a look at the entire
picture of idle labor resources
and it's not just the number of
unemployed it's the number of people
who are technically not counted as part
of the workforce
so they're not part of the unemployed
but they're outside the labor force but
if they were offered a job they would
take one well with that those are the
people that actually got the jobs last
month
just take a look at the number of people
who are um
not in the labor force but would take a
job if they wanted one you want to take
a look at the at the millions of
americans who are working
part-time but want a full-time job
you know that is actually an excess
capacity
in the labor market remember when you
talk about a six percent unemployment
rate
in the u.s uh or any country uh
the statisticians are treating a
part-time job the same as you're
treating
a full-time job so you have to take a
look also at the number of people who
are working part-time but actually don't
want to work part-time they want a
full-time job
and you add that in uh and um
you end up coming up with a number when
all said and done
the total pool of available labor uh
is about 17 million uh i mean it's 7
million deeper
than it was uh when the pandemic started
so
you know all this talk about um you know
shortages of labor
uh i mean really really we we have
a u6 the broadest measure of
unemployment
is 10.4 percent uh a tight labor market
is when that metric is closer to eight
percent
we are light years away from that um so
there's probably
a variety of factors related again to
the pandemic
and the policy response to the pandemic
that is not allowing that pool of labor
to be fully unleashed for the business
sector
i'm not convinced that's a permanent uh
condition
i imagine that look if the government
wants to continue to roll over jobless
benefits
the way that they are or we move to some
uh universal basic income situation if
the u.s
you know if i guess if if americans
voted in joe biden
if america's voting joe biden thinking
thankfully he's going to take us into a
european model
okay well you know go for it um but
i think a lot of this is temporary right
now i'm just saying like
you know we could talk about you know
company calls
uh and all the lamenting about job
shortages
and you mentioned bill dunkelberg and so
the survey
data but you know how how do you square
that
with the actual hard data how do you
square
labor shortage with a 10 and a half
percent u6 unemployment
when you know from history that the
title market only really
coexists with an eight percent u6
so i think there's a lot of temporary uh
developments that are related again to
the pandemic and the policy response to
the pandemic
and maybe we're in the seventh inning or
eighth inning
but we're still part of this game uh but
it's hard for me to wrap my head around
all the all the anecdotes and all the
lamenting and all the survey data and
all the diffusion indices
with the actual number of idle
labor resources in the united states
something tells me that
not today but by the fall we're going to
see a lot of that
excess supply come back in the market by
the way that will be disinflationary
not inflationary although you know so
many people can't see
past the tip of their nose they focus on
the trees and they can't see the forest
past the trees
but this labor this idle labor uh will
ultimately come back in
once the incentives that the government
created
to keep them on the sidelines start to
dissipate it's just a matter of timing
well and i think that there are plenty
of companies you know lobbying
on capitol hill saying no moss
no moss we don't want to pay up for
labor at 60 percent of our cost
structure so
i think the political winds will also
shift uh in favor of
you know companies that butter the bread
in in the inside the beltway
let me just say this you know i i don't
you know
again it's you can find there's gaps
between the rhetoric
the anecdotes surveys and the actual
data
and uh today's new york times
ran uh with the uh op-ed piece from our
good friend paul krugman
uh who's joined us several times for
your famous dinners in new york
and um he wrote a piece today that
i mean i i highlighted my breakfast with
dave about this was the best read of the
day
where he was talking about what we're
talking about right now
and and he had a a wells fargo uh report
from february 2013 with the headlines
screaming
you know labor shortages everywhere
companies can't find enough labor
we've hit the wall
inflationary wages are gonna it was
february 2013 danielle the same thing
so there's the belly aching the
lamenting the surveys the anecdotes the
bill duncan perks
but you know the reality is that the
the the report that he cited from wells
fargo
february 2013 and the expansion kept on
going for almost another seven years
the unemployment kept on going down and
guess what
we never hit the wall on labor and we
never got the accelerating wage growth
go figure
so um you and our fishing buddy
philippa dunn you do a great job of
getting all the way in the weeds and
sometimes the weeds tell us more than
kind of the headlines and you brought up
some historic moves
uh in the diffusion indices can you kind
of explain
what the implications are because the
moves were big yeah we had uh i mean
they're down to a three-month low but we
had the
precipitous decline and it's only
happened i think through the times in
the past where
uh the diffusion index went down as much
as it did uh you know from the high 70s
to around 60 percent
and just explain that's the percentage
of companies that are hiring yeah
it's a look the diffusion indices and
these uh paper reports is a measure of
dispersion
uh what percentage of uh of companies or
industries are actually adding to
payrolls and that number went down a lot
so it's telling you that um that only uh
barely more than fifty percent almost
sixty percent were actually adding jobs
forty percent weren't
that's not a very good number uh and so
what it's telling you is that there are
still lots of industries out there and
lots of companies within industries
uh that we're still shedding labor you
know i'm trying to again
you know it's interesting that we're
supposed to be having a booming economy
uh and we're reopening uh
i mean i was looking at the at the level
of unemployment
in every single industry in the united
states
it's so far above where we were when we
weren't full employment in the last
cycle
you know back in early 2020 there's not
a sector that doesn't have
an incredible amount of of slack in
terms of unemployment
um so that was what was surprising to me
is that you know we're talking about the
diffusion index i mean all the jobs
that were created were in areas that you
would think would benefit from the
reopening and it did
we had job gains in uh in leisure
hospitality
and amusement parks and casinos and
gambling and hotels and motels
that was all the job gains and that's
you know i estimated that that was
twenty percent
of the employment pie created all the
jobs and then some but what about the
other eighty percent
like there was no growth in construction
no growth in construction
well of course part of that is because
you had gains in housing-related
residential but non-residential was very
weak
uh what happened with manufacturing
these unbelievably great ism indices
and and manufacturing payrolls were
actually down
admittedly a lot of that in the
automotive industry um
and i'm looking at trucking uh down to
the past three months
very highly cyclical sensitive area of
the market
stocks in the s p are going to new highs
uh and maybe that's an area where
they're having trouble finding workers
although once again i looked industry by
industry at the pool of labor in each
industry
and maybe they're all getting
unemployment benefits they don't feel
like going back to work or could well be
like i said before what we don't know
for sure is how much of residual fear
there is
nice to have the vaccination rates above
40 we don't know
that's the other part of it like you
know i know we're going to capitol hill
and
complaining to the government but at the
same time
you know um uh you know uh i'm running a
company i'm running my own company
i'm pretty sure that if i opened up
downtown
or we're all working rolly right now i'm
not so sure everybody want to go back
downtown
at this stage and of course canada is
vaccinated at a fraction that the us has
but there's that that lingering consent
we're still you know
you know we're still living in this
pandemic and people are expecting that
we're going to have normal employment
conditions normal economic conditions
just because things are reopening
not everything is fully reopened but
there's still part of that fear factor
you know back to the diffusion index is
telling you that there's lots of
industries out there
like take a look for example like why
would financial what you tell me what
what
the financial industry never really lost
jobs in this that's right
that's one area where so what would you
expect right now is the financial sector
adding jobs
no so that's one of the reasons why the
fusion index was weak what's the finance
why would financials be be adding or
doing this
real estate agents do we need more of
those at this stage so
there's so many other parts of the
economy that didn't get hurt by the
pandemic
and they don't need more workers because
there's no kind of demand there
yep um so that's the other element of
this is we're all looking at the job
gains job gains where yeah
restaurants and movie theaters and theme
parks and hotels
but there's so much there's so much the
economy on the merchandise side
uh that never got hurt that didn't even
suffer any job loss so
why would you be expecting that those
would be areas where we're going to be
seeing job growth so that's that's
one of the factors you know impairing
that diffusion index that we're talking
about right now
so um put you know there was a lot of
celebration on wall street because
jobless claims broke
underneath 500 000 for the first time
since the pandemic
i'm sorry but 500 000 is still
historically speaking uh quite a big
number when you consider what the
starting point was
well yeah i i wrote about this the other
day you know
you'd be thinking that with all all the
jubilation and all the
reopening and and that that'd be zero
like that's the other thing i'm trying
to wrap around my head for all the
bellyaching lamenting
uh blaming can't find labor can't find
labor can't find labor
and yet we get jobless claims and people
talk about well look how far down
they've come well no kidding
that they've come down with an improving
economy but why aren't they at zero
and that's an extreme comment but in a
normal economy
in a normal economy jobless claims in
any given week is around 200 000
so you're quite right we're more than
double what a normal
why why and remember that jobless claims
are a flow
of firings
that's all they are they are a flow
they're not a stock so you're talking
about a change on a change
so the change in the change is going
down but it's change itself
is more than double what a normal
economy is so i mean i come back i mean
i
you know for those people that say we're
going to blame government
you know we're going to blame jobless uh
benefit packages i mean maybe that's all
true
i mean that's you hear a lot about that
but then somebody doesn't come back and
say well that's all true
why are you firing people if you're
having so much trouble
uh finding people to work
why are you firing people 500 000 in a
given week
and that's supposed to be a good week so
you see it you know
that's what i'm talking about it is very
confusing it's confounding
i keep on coming back we are not in a
normal
period of time thankfully we're past the
eye of the storm the vaccinations were a
game changer
we are not out of this thing by a long
shot and i don't know why people think
that
anything's coming back to normal or that
quickly and that's what the data are
telling you you got people saying i
can't find workers
at the same time jobless claims are 500
000. well
so so don't let those people go then and
you and you won't have a problem
you know with the job shortages so
there's a tremendous amount of
inconsistency
in the data and there's actually even
more consistency between the narratives
that you're hearing today
and the data so um i'm i'm going to go
there
dave i'm going there i'm going to hit
the inflation button um
you know again you mentioned the ism
prices paid or it are being reported at
record highs whether you're talking
about manufacturing or services
commodities inflation is through the
roof um
the supply chain disruption i mean i say
supply chain disruption in my sleep at
this point
shipping freight costs i mean companies
are they imagining this inflation and
oh and by the way china's sitting on
record levels
of a lot of these commodities
no i'd say that um we do have
uh inflation right now but it's i mean i
you know look i spent probably 80
percent of my career
actually disagreeing with the fed but i
agree with jay powell on this i think
that he's right i think that we are
having a
a temporary boat of inflation pressure
um
but it's temporary and if you're a
central bank you're not going to change
policy based on a deviation around a
trend line you'll change policy if you
believe that trend line is changing
well let's go back to your comment about
the ism
price is paid it's actually the at its
highest level since uh
the summer of 2008.
let me just tell you something about the
summer 2008 danielle because
oil prices wti got 240 dollars
in a short time period in a year more
than doubled it was 140 dollars not 65.
and i went through a lot of internal
pressure in the summer of oh wait
remember the summer of 08
everybody thought that bear stearns was
behind us everybody thought
that the housing correction was behind
us if you remember everybody thought the
recession was over
the european central bank in the summer
of 08 under trisha raised rates
and bernanke actually switched to a
tightening bias
because of inflation commodity inflation
and the ism prices paid index by the way
is not a leading indicator
it's just telling you if you want to
draw the ism price is paid against the
crb
it's the same as the same chart it's not
a leading indicator
i don't know why anybody would take the
ism prices paid
and extrapolate from it i mean were you
doing that last year when ism prices
paid was down at the floor
uh would you have been saying we're
going into a pernicious sustained
deflationary environment
and would you be saying it today at the
peak but remember we're
back at the levels back we were in
summer 2008 when the narrative was
basically pretty well the same
the shock is over and we know for a fact
that it wasn't over we didn't know
that lehman and aig was lying around the
bend
you know you read the financial
stability report
or what i call the financial instability
report that was just published yesterday
uh you know i'm more concerned about
excessive asset inflation
and if that rolls over what that's going
to mean you know that people
the inflation rate the inflation rate
got to five percent in the summer of 008
and people are going crazy over
inflation
without realizing it's a lagging
indicator so the ism price is paid yes
yes yes the highest levels since summer
of 08. the summer of my weight inflation
was five percent
did the ism prices pay tell you in 12
months time that inflation was going to
negative 2
how do you know danielle how do you know
that inflation's not gonna be minus two
percent
a year from now now i'm not going to say
that we should have the answer to that
question but i would not be looking for
the clues from the ism prices paid
which is at the same level it was in the
summer of 08 at the peak of the
commodity cycle
and a year later the commodity cycle as
commodity cycles all do there's only
been 15 of them since 1950 that's all
you look at the year over year chart of
the crb
it looks like a series of sine waves
so no i don't have a big inflation story
for you i think that
we again we are living in this
unusual period of time it's not over
there's been all sorts of distortions
distortions
with the pandemic distortions with the
reopening distortions with the
vaccinations previously the lockdowns
it's been a rollercoaster ride
but remember that the initial impact of
the pandemic
last year was that it was a much
more acute demand shock than supply
shock
so march april may of 2020
cpi printed negative was it temporary
yes and now we're printing some hefty
increases and it's not just base effects
there's other things going on
and so we're going through a temporary
period uh of inflationary pressure
because now
with the reopenings and the fiscal juice
and
the fact of the matter is that now
demand is running well ahead of supply
and we're getting some near-term
inflation what's the fed so the fed's
going to raise interest rates fed policy
hits the economy
with lags that are 12 to 24 months
and if the fed believes this is all
temporary then
why would you change policy on something
you believe is transitory now look maybe
there's a chance that they'll be wrong
but we have to understand we've got a
significant demand boost from
what from what from stimulus checks
stimulus checks and uh there
that impact's going to run out the
jobless benefit impact will run out this
is all happening in the third and fourth
quarter so demand naturally is going to
subside
and i find it disingenuous to suggest
that
we'll have reopening and it will only
have an impact on demand for no impact
on supply
but we're going to have an impact on
supply and i could tell you that yes we
have shortages right now
but i'm looking at the container
data in the ports of la and the ports of
long beach the two busiest
ports in the united states they are
filled to the brim
filled to the brim of merchandise ready
to be unloaded
uh so supply is coming back uh
i'm hearing all about semiconductor
shortages well i'm looking at the export
and shipment numbers
out of korea and taiwan they are through
the roof
i'm looking at canadian lumber
production through the roof
so to suggest that supply is not going
to come back
online with a lag to me is uh
is nonsensical so yeah we have a
near term and i would say a temporary
inflation situation just as a year ago
we had a temporary deflation
situation but do i think it's going to
be
long lasting or persistent uh i have a
tough time believing that
and i'll tell you it's only because uh
you mean taking a look at
the degree of excess capacity in the
economy now
trying to estimate where the output gap
is that's
always very difficult thing to do but we
have an industry
cap you rate of 74 we have a
new sex unemployment rate of
almost 10 and a half percent and the
other two times in the past we had that
condition
in the product market and labor market
uh was in late 2001
in the summer 2008 and they did not
produce an inflationary outcome
for the next couple of years so um you
know
the predictions are that that that car
sales and home sales are just going to
continue
at this insane clip going
forward uh but you uh you've got some
pretty
pretty cogent insights into
you can't ring the bell twice we're not
going to see what we saw
in terms of of household purchasing
goods
all over again well if
i went back through the history
to see the last time for example the
last number of times that
auto sales were 18 and a half million
units
i mean there was a very strong april
and they were down in the next six
months precipitously
each and every time we brought forward a
lot of consumption
and the same is true with uh you know uh
over a million on new home sales
1.7 million on housing starts uh these
are all back to levels we had in o five
and oh six
we brought forth a lot of consumption
but not just in housing and autos but
you know durable goods
in general uh so i mean one of my
premises has been that yes we're going
to have the big party
uh if you i mean i have a trouble with
the concept of pent up demand and
services
uh that doesn't really exist wait wait
wait wait dave but there's all this
savings on the sideline there's pent-up
there's pent-up
spending because the saving rate is at
the highest in
you know the history of mankind blah
blah blah you know i'm egging you on
yeah well let me get to the part about
let me get to the savings rate in a
second
but we're going to have and it's already
starting i mean you saw it in the
consumer spending report uh in uh that
we got for march
it's already starting uh that you're
seeing service sector spending
um which collapsed last year coming back
i wouldn't exactly call a pent up demand
because
you're not going to make up for that you
know you're not gonna
go to the restaurant six times every day
for the next several months to make up
for the lost consumption last year
not gonna get your hair cut four times a
day because you didn't go to the barber
last year so
it's a nebulous concept about the
pent-up demand and services but it's
gonna come back but remember
it's an 800 billion dollar or four
percent chunk of gdp we're having a
jubilation celebration amongst the
economist over
a v shape recovery and four percent of
gdp go knock yourself out
um but the two trillion dollar chunk is
consumer durable goods
uh and and over the past year that
spending in volume terms is up 44
uh we haven't seen something like that
since 1950 i mean so we had so because
of course you know we
we we couldn't go out we couldn't go to
restaurants couldn't travel
so you know people spent money on their
homes or they bought a new car if you
saw the data
on pleasure boats pleasure aircraft
furniture appliances electronics home
remodeling that
you would not have ever guessed we had a
recession last year
durable good spending normally goes down
in a recession
and it skyrocketed um so i would say
that there is no pent up demand
for a share of consumer spending that's
double
what consumer cyclical services are this
is almost a two trillion dollar market
it's completely satiated now i can't
you will not convince me that all these
stimulus checks are going to be used
towards
another dining room table because you
already bought one last year are you
going to fit two tables
in your dining room are you going to
build an extra swimming pool
are you going to redo your remodel your
basement again
all that stuff is done again i said this
is a very unusual time in history
but there's no pent up demand i'd say
there's actually pen down demand
in a nearly 2 trillion dollar chunk of
consumer spending
called consumer durable goods we are hit
the satiation point
i have a chart in my presentation
package that shows
household durable goods assets per
capita
that chart looks like a dot com stock
from 1999
uh and so no one talks about what's
going to happen
to that part of consumer spending even
as we go we fly and we eat out
and we go to museums and so on and so
forth
so the other part is your comment about
the savings rate
and of course that's the lingering
impact of all the stimulus checks so the
savings rate right now
is call it roughly 30 percent uh the
pre-covert
equilibrium was for like seven percent
but who knows
where the savings rate is going to be
going i mean who knows where it's going
to be going that
like you see everybody talks about this
dry powder for spending
but i'm asking you danielle where are
you going to spend it like where are you
going to spend it
um are you going to say well you know
i'm going to stay at the most expensive
hotel on my trip
uh i'm going to um you know i'm going to
eat out of the best restaurant like
where are you going to spend it because
you've already spent so much
on durable goods which is such a bigger
share
of consumer spreading where are you
going to spend it well right now they're
spending
it on on the thing is that you don't you
can take the horse to water doesn't mean
that the horse is going to drink i think
people have underestimated how high
the savings rate is going to be for a
long period of time
and let's not forget that the fastest
growing share
of the demographics are people 65 and up
and that's going to continue for the
next 10 years so people will
also be thinking about their retirement
but let's just say
stick to the facts the facts are these
the facts are that the new york fed has
done the work for every single economist
out there
they looked at where the money was spent
they followed the money through stimulus
check number one under the cares act
stimulus check number two
under donald trump signing on to the 900
billion on december 27th
and now this latest one under joe
and the numbers hardly move less than 25
percent of the
stimulus checks go into actual spending
and maybe that's what somebody said to
joe biden said you got to go big because
so little of it actually goes into the
economy
so a third of it is going to pay down
debt
i'm looking at the numbers on bank
lending
now you got these bankers they're
smiling their stock price has done great
we saw their bank earnings numbers for
the last quarter so are they making
their money outside of unleashing
loan loss reserves they're making
capital markets wealth management and
trading
their loan book is going down i'm
looking every week at the bank lending
data and not just to businesses but the
households it is undergoing an epic
contraction
people are actually paying down debt
and so less than 25 percent of this
money
that they're getting this windfall from
government is actually going into the
real economy now it's a
it's still a big number it's going to
subside at some point
but it's an interesting comment on
behavior that less than 25
of this stimulus is actually going into
the economy
and the rest is being split between debt
pay down and saving slash investment
savings investment which is you know
your robin hood account
um so that's really what the story here
is um
we have actually in the overall
context of how gigantic the stimulus is
and the impact it's had temporarily on
personal income which is
without precedent bigger than lbj's
great society
it's interesting that less than a
quarter has been put into the economy
what happens when the well runs dry
danielle
and so i say that people will be
surprised at how high now
it's not going to stay at 30 percent
people will be surprised how high the
savings rate is going to be for a
prolonged period of time
so um step back into your old role
as the housing expert what is going on
i mean i i know friends who are bidding
up
homes like insanely i'm
i'm i'm baffled at some of these home
prices right now
well it's like uh you know in an era
where interest rates are very low
long-duration assets do very well you're
even seeing
the growth stocks come back uh now the
bond deals have come back down
but you got look you've got very tight
housing markets
and you've had a shift in preference uh
coming out of the pandemic for home
ownership
um and people are looking at their house
differently they're also looking at
their house
as uh as their workplace you know much
like i have here uh i'm a
home right now this is my office so lots
of secular changes are taking place uh
there's not a lot of supply
the new home sales numbers don't lie you
know over a million units we haven't
seen that
uh you know since the the boom years
when i was back in merrell back in the
0.506
so we have a supply demand mismatch uh
you could argue that there's also
quite a bit of speculative activity
going on
and i say that because when you look at
the data only 30
of the home sales are actually coming
from first-time buyers a lot of it are
all cash
investor deals oh they're pension funds
they're coming from overseas
it's insanity but but the the the
problem i have with housing
is just more of a valuation
it's the same thing with the stock
market i i have nothing against the
stock market it's just
in this auction it's become so expensive
you know people will say well there's a
guy who knows the price of everything
but the value of nothing but the reality
is that uh the same house
quality adjusted uh is rising double
digits
uh you know and no that doesn't make a
lot of sense usually housing
you know you always talked about
residential real estate as an inflation
hedge yeah because it usually
would appreciate with inflation
alongside a one to two point premium
over inflation uh and now that premium
is more like 15 percentage points
you look at house prices normalized by
the cpi
and and we know the cpi is rising right
now uh
look at all prices normalized by rent
home price is normalized by income so
you take a look at housing
with a a classic p e ratio and danielle
these are all the charts i was looking
at
when i was planning a fist on the table
over the housing bubble
you know back in 06.07 and i'm going to
adhere it
to bob farrell's 10 marker rules to
remember everybody knows that rule
number one
is that markets tend to return to the
mean over time
now not levels but rate everything i'm
talking about here are ratios
we have a housing market in the united
states nationwide
uh where prices relative to their
underlying fundamentals
are more than 20 percent overvalued what
would that mean to have a 20
correction in home prices and then the
same thing with the equity market
which is more like 30 percent overvalued
and it was interesting to see
actually in the financial instability
report that they
had just published oh yeah that they
came out and said that actually the
stock market even when you adjust for
interest rates
uh is trading at uh at exuberant levels
uh and so uh i'm a little and this comes
back actually talk about housing i'm
looking at the whole household balance
sheet
we're at it again we're we're back to
relying on asset inflation
as a source of prosperity in the country
uh and it's troublesome
uh when i take a look at household net
worth the disposable income
it's it's up to 770 percent
uh we're already a hundred percentage
points higher on that ratio than we were
uh at the peak of the housing bubble
back in the late 2000s and we're 150
percentage points on that ratio
than we were during the the tech craze
back
in the late 1990s never been this high
and uh the san francisco fed
back in early 2018 put a report showing
how
the household network to disposal income
ratio
is a main reverting series and it is and
i shudder to think what happens
uh if that does end up mean reverting uh
and uh the asset deflation we're
probably going to see
is going to knock this consumer
inflation story off the front pages of
the paper
and i think everybody should go and read
what the fed published yesterday on
their financial stability report i call
it instability
i mean look it's a bad joke but but
people
people are looking people are looking at
the wrong thing they're looking at the
wrong thing if you were looking at this
unbelievable nosebleed net worth to
income ratio
uh instead of oil prices
in 2008 your
investment performance the next year
would have been a lot better people are
looking at the wrong things they're
looking at yesterday's story
which is the year of a year percent
change in the cpi and what commodities
have done without understanding that
supply is going to catch up
what they aren't factoring in is is in
fact what the fed was talking about
yesterday
which is that we do in fact have bubbles
they might as well just use the word
bubbles but they can't use that word
well look i'm going to tell you when
these bubbles burst when these bubbles
burst danielle we are not going to be
talking about inflation and anything
more than we were
coming off 140 oil in the summer 2008.
dave as a former fed insider i cannot
tell you
how rare it is to see
such plain language in the financial
instability report
i mean they they the fed has has made an
art
of dancing around the discussion
evaluations
for generations so when they come out
like they did like leo brainerd did and
she is the presumed front-runner
if jay powell's not re-nominated i mean
that that is
it's a rare moment to see that officials
be so blunt
uh well you know it started with powell
during his presser in the q a when he
used the word
froth not once but twice and he no
longer as he once was is justifying
equity valuations
based on where interest rates are uh
and of course it wasn't just the stock
market but it was also
the spax and the ipos
leveraged hedge funds uh look we have a
situation on our hands
everything is just smacking
and it's funny to say because you know
we're a year
past the bottom of the stock market a
year past the bottom
in the economy and employment but it's
still in the context of this very
unusual
situation we have in our hands i would
actually argue that maybe the biggest
bubble out there is in corporate credit
i mean how how can we how can we call it
a high yield market
when the interest rate in the high yield
market is barely more than four percent
you've got a situation where uh
the spread between
triple c rated debt and single b's
triple c's of course are distressed
the tightest levels they've been since
2007 well we all know about 2007 in
hindsight
is that is basically peak of market peak
of cycle
so everything is just screaming uh
bubble
but i would say that amongst everything
else we're talking about right now
the high yield market the distressed
debt market everything that has to do
with the riskiest tranches of corporate
debt
that is an accident waiting to happen
well if that's an accident waiting to
happen and we'll we'll wrap up with this
uh you did some interesting math uh
about loving the long bond uh
i mean that i said i said how many
percent
what i had i looked back and i almost i
almost shot you a text to ask if it was
a typo
but walk us through sure well look
um you know that everybody talks about
uh the tips break even so you can't you
can't you can't open up your bloomberg
terminal
turn it on every morning the tips break
evens the inflation expectations of the
bond market haven't been this high
10 15 years it's a record highs and so
the tips break evens um depending on
which maturity
two and a half 2.6
uh and so the the the markets already
priced for
the inflation the peak inflation of the
last cycle when unemployment was three
and a half percent
were nowhere near that but the market's
already priced that in look when you're
taking a look at the tips breakevens
what are they correlated with danielle
they're poorly with the crb index
okay to the bond trader in the futures
and option pits
their inflation model is a one variable
model
and it's got the crb index okay
when you go the cleveland fed every
month produces its own
model of inflation expectations going
out maturities to 30 years
and when you look at five years or ten
years and of course they moved off the
bottom
uh but they're roughly one and a half
one point six percent
that's but you see the cleveland model
is like a real model
and that has at least a correlation with
the labor market
because how can you do any inflation
forecast without 70 percent of the cost
structure called labor in there
so the cleveland fed model is actually a
real model
it's not a one variable model but their
inflation expectation
from their model is 100 basis points
lower than it is
in the current bond market structure so
my comment was this and it's just pure
math and it's an f
it's an f if the market-based inflation
expectations
of the tips market converges on where
the cleveland fed
is it takes the long bond deal back to
where it was in september of
last year i'm not saying that we're
going back to september of the 1933 i'm
saying we'll go to september 2020
in that environment and because of the
law of low numbers and convexity as it
relates to total return
in the bond market the 30-year treasury
would generate you within a year
a 27 percent total return under the
proviso
then i'm right that the convergence is
with the tif spray evens
lining up on top of cleveland fed
inflation expectations but that's a very
interesting and actually unprecedented
anomaly between these two data series
well look just slice it down the middle
it's still
still awesome seriously so
um all right look i i can't thank you
enough for doing this last minute i'm
so excited we got to visit uh i hope
that um i hope everybody else is as
enlightened as i am it's always
great when you're this energetic and um
i look forward to getting that second
vaccine
and you get in an airplane but again uh
thank you so much for your time today
dave we really do appreciate it take
care
you too danielle thanks for inviting me
on all the best thank you
thank you enough for joining me for this
special edition
of down the middle i mean to have david
rosenberg
on non-farm payroll friday when the data
just literally went haywire and one
month does not make for a trend but
still
what a treat i hope you enjoyed it as
much as i did i hope you learned as much
as i did
and you know score one for the
contrarian thinker and that's kind of
how you have to be
in these kind of investing environments
you have to think differently
than the crowds so uh you know i look
forward to the next time that you join
me
thanks once again for being with me this
is danielle dimartino booth with down
the middle
thank you